in Colorado hundreds of people protested
outside an Aurora police station
demanding more disciplinary action
following the death of Elijah McLean
Friday's protests began hours after the
Police Department released a disturbing
photo that appears to show three
officers mocking MacLaine's death three
officers have been fired a fourth
resigned protest leaders say they plan
to surround the police station until the
department fires the two remaining
officers involved in MacLaine's death
Jamie yuccas has more for the first time
interim police chief Vanessa Wilson
revealed these photos were sickened and
were angry three officers laughing and
mocking the chokehold used on Elijah
McLane it shows a lack of morals values
and integrity and a judgment that I can
no longer trust to allow them to wear
this badge and they won't Wilson fired
Erika Marrero and Kyle Dietrich after
Jarron Jones resigned also fired a
fourth Officer Jason Rosenblatt who
responded haha to the picture he was
involved in the original incident
Elijah McLane was not accused of any
crime when officers used a chokehold on
him and paramedics injected him with a
sedative he later died those officers
were never charged with a crime to still
work for the department the FBI and
Department of Justice are investigating
McClane's father LuAnn Mosley had this
to say about the photo reenactment
you're a coward
and I hope you get what you deserve
because it's gonna be worth me seeing
that you're fired for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie yuccas Los Angeles